[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: So
Martin, you remember how we
were talking about Terraform?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, Katie.
It made me really
want to try it out.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well, how
about we try out some Terraform
provisioning right now?
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
So Martin, I can
see you've got a
new project set up.
And you've configured
billing, yes?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, that's right.
I have here Martin's Project,
and a bunch of numbers.
Yeah.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
So if you open up
the source code I
gave you over in GitHub--
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
There it is.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
And if you go down
to the README,
there's all the instructions
you need to get it working.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, excellent.
My cat photo
identification service.
All right.
Billing enabled,
launch Cloud Shell.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
So you can run all this in
Cloud Shell, because it already
has gcloud locally and
it also has Terraform
locally installed, as well.
And you can get
to the Cloud Shell
by clicking that little icon
in the Google Cloud Platform
Console.
So if you go into
the README, there
will be a git clone command
that you can clone the source
code into your Cloud Shell.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I
love it when it's simple.
All right.
Let's see.
Copy that.
Paste that git clone in there.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Mhm.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
And then you want
to go into the expeditions
directory, and then
the terraform directory.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Very good.
All right.
I'm there.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
And so from here, there
are three commands--
gcloud builds submit to
create the container,
and then two commands
to terraform.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
gcloud builds submit.
Oh, I had said project.
Let's do that.
And my project ID is up here.
Authorize that.
All right.
The build finished.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
And now it's just two
terraform commands--
first, terraform init.
MARTIN OMANDER: terraform init.
Very good.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: And
now terraform apply.
MARTIN OMANDER: terraform apply.
Project ID-- I have
that in my copy buffer.
Well, do I want to
perform these actions?
What should I say here?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Y-E-S for yes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Aha.
Yes, let's do it.
And it's done!
Looks like it's a
service URL here?
What's that?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: That's
your running service.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Should I click it?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Let's see.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Cats.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, look.
[LAUGHS] I have cats.
And we have some
image labels here?
Where do these labels come from?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
So would you like
to know what this service does?
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, please explain.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: So if you
go back to the GitHub repo,
I have got a architecture
diagram listed on the README
there, right at the end.
MARTIN OMANDER: Aha,
architectural diagram.
Nice.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: So this
is what's going on here.
What we've done is, as we
described in last week's video,
we had to create
a container first.
So we used Cloud Build to
create a container that
then stored that container
in Container Registry.
And then we used Terraform.
We have, or I already
created, a whole bunch
of manifests that would
do all the steps required
by Terraform--
was going and
creating a whole bunch
of IAM permissions, service
enablement, and the like.
It then created a Cloud Run
bucket and a whole bunch
of sample cats that we saw.
It then created a function,
and then it created a service.
What we have is a
service that goes
through all the
images in a bucket,
and for each of those
images, sends them off
to Cloud Functions and asks
Cloud Functions to talk
to the Vision API to get
information about each image.
In this case, it's
a cat, and we're
asking it to describe the image.
So it's coming back with
labels like cats, whiskers,
and the like.
Those results then
come back to Cloud Run,
and then it displays all the
results in that lovely web
page.
MARTIN OMANDER: Nice.
So these four boxes were
all automatically deployed
with that one terraform
apply command?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yep.
Easy, isn't it?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
So they are all in here
somewhere in my project now?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
So if you want to
go to Cloud Run,
you can see the service
has been created.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Let's see.
All right.
I see the cats service here.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: So you can see
the service has been created.
Because we did all
this in Terraform,
the Console is having
to start from cold.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, yeah.
I clicked on Revisions.
I see there's one revision here.
It's getting 100%
of the traffic.
This is looking good.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
We also created the
Cloud Run function,
which if you go
over to Functions,
you can see that there.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Cloud Functions.
Let's have a look.
All right, so I'm in Functions.
Ah, we have a function
called processing here.
Aha.
So here I can see the source
code of that function that
was part of the project.
Very nice.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: And then
the last major thing we did
was create the Cloud Storage
bucket and pre-populate it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
That's those cat pictures
we saw a minute ago, right?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
We're in Cloud Storage.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
The bucket I created
is the one that has
media on the end.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, OK.
Let's have a look.
Mhm, and it looks like
some cat pictures.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
So what I did in
this case, Martin,
is I created all these
elements in Terraform.
But I also pre-populated the
bucket with some sample cats.
That way, you can see that
your service is working.
What we can do now is we
can delete those cats.
Because we created
them in Terraform,
we can recreate them again.
So what we can do
is remove those cats
and get Terraform to
recreate them for us.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Let's try it.
Delete them.
All right.
Feels a little scary,
but I trust you, Katie.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: In
this case, Terraform
created this sample data, so it
can recreate this sample data.
Please do not go deleting
everything from your buckets.
MARTIN OMANDER: [LAUGHS] And--
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: If
you reload the service--
MARTIN OMANDER: --how do I
get them back with Terraform?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Reload
the service first,
just to show that the
cats have gone away.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
OK, so here was
the cat pictures.
Oh, I have no cats.
That's so sad.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
I have no cats.
So if you go back
to Cloud Shell,
--the last command we
ran was terraform apply.
So if you want to
run that again--
and maybe make the
window a little bit
bigger, because we're going
to start looking at some
of the Terraform output now.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, OK.
Cool.
There we go.
Let's see if I
have the project--
yeah-- project ID
in my copy buffer.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
So last time, you
may have noticed we were
creating 18 elements.
This time, we're only creating
a smaller set of elements.
Terraform has identified
that our desired
state of the project
requires us to recreate
these three images and some
other smaller bits of metadata.
But--
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
I see.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: --you
can type Y-E-S again
and get all the cats back.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yes.
Let's get the--
ooh, that was quick.
All right.
So if I hit the
service over here now,
we should hopefully
see some cats?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Mhm.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
The cats are back.
Oh, I love this, how if anything
went awry with the service,
I could just easily recreate it.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: That's one
of the powers of Terraform.
Now, there are some
limitations to how much
Terraform can save you from
misconfigured projects.
But this is an example of how
Terraform can recreate some
of these resources for you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
Cool.
I have to keep on entering
the project ID here.
That's a little annoying.
Can we do something about that?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: We can.
So what we'll do is we'll
do two things at once here.
We'll get you to
reapply terraform again,
and we'll also get you
to define that variable.
So if you go terraform apply,
but before you hit Enter,
go space, -var space, project=
and then your project name.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I see.
Let's do that.
Now, this is a working
application here.
Is it safe to run terraform
apply again when everything
is working as it should?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yep.
In theory, Terraform
will not see any changes,
or any changes that it does
see are little tiny differences
in metadata or something
that it doesn't control.
But whenever you
run terraform apply,
you should just check
what's going to be applied.
And then if you're comfortable
with those changes, type Y-E-S.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Y-E-S. Let's do it.
Boom.
That was quick.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Would you
like to destroy everything now?
MARTIN OMANDER: [GASPS] Destroy?
It sounds dangerous, but
we did get the cat pictures
back before.
OK, I'll trust you.
Let's do it.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
Disclaimer-- in this case,
we are using a brand-new
separate project that we
created with Terraform,
all the elements
we created with Terraform.
So now we're going
to get Terraform
to undo all the resource
creation that it applied.
So if you're ready, Martin,
if you want to type terraform
destroy.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, my gosh.
terraform destroy.
Like so?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yep.
And you're going to have to
enter in your project, as well.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, OK.
Should we do this--
whoops-- -var project=--
there it is.
All right.
Let's do it.
18 things will be destroyed.
Oh, my gosh.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: We
created 18 things,
now we're going to
destroy 18 things.
So if you're ready, Martin,
Y-E-S, and Terraform
will remove everything
that it created.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, my.
All right, so it's destroyed.
Now if I hit this, the
application of the web page--
oh, my gosh.
It's not even I have no cats.
It's literally a 404.
The URL doesn't exist, eh?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: We
destroyed everything.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow, OK.
How do I get it back?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
terraform apply.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, really?
OK, let's do that.
All right.
18 things will be
added, it says.
OK, let's do it.
All right.
The terraform apply is all done.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah, and
your cats should now be back.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Oh, let's see here.
So, OK, before, I
got a 404 error,
because the service
had been removed.
Ah, the cats are back.
I'm relieved.
That was really cool, Katie.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Did
you want to take a look
at what the Terraform manifests
look like, while we're here?
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, yes.
What's the magic that
makes all of this happen?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: No magic,
just the careful application
of configuration files.
MARTIN OMANDER:
[LAUGHS] Very good.
Let's have a look.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
You can go to GitHub,
or we can use the
Cloud Shell Editor.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
I'm going to GitHub.
I'll go up in the
directory here.
Ah, .tf-- does that have
anything to do with it?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yep, .tf
is for Terraform manifest.
So there are a couple
of manifests in here.
The three main ones that are
standard names for Terraform
manifests are the main, which
is the main file, variables
for variables, and then
outputs for outputs.
Each of the other
manifests that I
have there for
this demonstration
are just a logical
separation of each
of the different components--
the function for functions,
the service for service,
media for media, et cetera.
Those folders that
I've got in there
are also just the source code.
So if you have a
look at the function,
you'll end up with
the requirements.txt
and the application file that we
saw earlier in Cloud Functions.
So that's just
the function code.
Same for the service code.
But it's those Terraform
manifests that define--
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, the service
is the Cloud Run service?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Aha.
Cool.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: But
it's those manifests
that define what we want
our project state to be.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
They list the services,
and the buckets,
and everything that's
in these .tf files.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
So, Katie, I have one
more question for you.
When I was running
this terraform apply,
it always asked me
to input yes, Y-E-S,
to actually make it happen.
Can I automate
that away, as well?
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Yes, but.
You can automate it away.
You can auto-approve, but
when you are running Terraform
locally, you really should be
checking what you're doing.
For automation pipelines
and continuous deployment,
you can't have a
human type Y-E-S.
So there are ways
Terraform can do that.
But when you're learning,
make sure that you actually
go back and read what Terraform
is going to do, especially
if you start destroying
stuff, just to make sure
that you're in
the right project,
that you're manipulating the
resources that you expect.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, cool.
Got it.
Well, I can't wait to write
some Terraform manifests
and replace these
long README files I've
been sending to my customer.
This is very exciting stuff.
Thank you for showing me, Katie.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Absolutely
no worries, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Thank you for watching.
And if you have any questions or
any suggestions for new topics
we should bring up
in these episodes,
please enter them in
the comments below.
Thank you.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]